tu tombé sur un chiffre aujourd'hui 64%
des français gardent contact avec leur
ex 6 ouf alors garde contact ou peuvent
repêchons le rex je pars d'un principe
et je vais d'exposer aux téléspectateurs
c'est quand tu galoche une meuf une fois
tu peux la galoche mille fois quoi ouais
ça finit comment ça et c'est pareil pour
un mec c'est toi ou pas accès au jeu
tony si si si ça va deux fois c'est fini
par la loi quand même si tu l'obligea
t'embrasser vous estimez que appartement
où vous avez une petite aventure avec
quelqu'un vous pouvez retomber dans les
bras
alors ça marche pour les hommes
pour les autres c'est jamais fini ouais
c'est un club sain c'est fini oui c'est
qu'il est c'est fini c'est fini
artistiquement c'est fini c'est vrai que
ça peut repartir tout mais c'est vrai on
crierait qui revoit son ex qui a déjà
replongé avec une extra carrière
carrière qui est de retour christophe
gaillard à l'express
[Applaudissements]
alors oui on replonge et non mais gardé
un très bon contact avec mon ex oui mais
pareil que voulait quand même l'art
pécho dit la vérité vous êtes encore
amoureux dès lors s de mythos la
deuxième wii avec qui je vis une semaine
sur deux excusez moi vous êtes qui
comprend pas le racontez nous votre
histoire c'est quoi bon je vais suit
d'abord il ya la mère de mes filles avec
qui on partage un appartement d'accord
qu'elle ya nos enfants donc les enfants
ne bouge pas donc on s'entend très grave
donc en fait les enfants résonne même
appart et vous vous n'habitez
appartement sa façade
voilà ça va quand on travaille à
l'express on à l'oseille non ça ça me
coûte un bras joue devant mais bon ça
vous quelquefois sans doute pas des
choses et oui alors j'ai dit ça j'ai une
chérie mais qui me dit on n'est plus
ensemble
un macédonien de série alors laissez le
finir beinheim sait déjà c'est dur c'est
assez compliqué les gens ne comprennent
plus rien moi non plus d'ailleurs
c'était une chérie elle vous habite avec
el mahmudi que c'est fini oui une
semaine sur deux pistes une semaine je
suis avec mes enfants une semaine chez
avec elle met donc elle à elle à
quelqu'un d'autre
non sur bah oui quand youri chérie je
sais pas dix mois mais alors c'est votre
move c'est pas votre 9
ben c'est si c'est ma meuf mais on n'est
plus ensemble mais la conscience et non
mais non est-ce que tu suis pour l'amour
avec elle
bravo c'est la question je voulais pas
passer ses soirées c'est vrai on se dit
tout oui après d'entre nous la vie oui
bon ça peut arriver voilà ça barrier
donc non c'est pas que c'est pas
vraiment ça 9 c'est pour l'instant c'est
entre les deux c'est ce qu'on appelle
une meuf une vitrine à la c2 1 celle de
boy next door vous oui enfin on a quand
même été ensemble bien près même en
avant donc là c'est mort on sait pas
mort
[Musique]
regardons s'est pas mariée j'ai pas fait
de demande n'est rien on va traîner
entraîner alors les autres qui renvoie
ses ex bah vous c'est difficile
d'enchaîner envoyer vos ex heures je
suis fâché qu'aucune ex nantes à la
maire du ve vous êtes tellement gentil
où c'est vrai mais je fais pas de
saloperies je fais pas tout le petit
chéri c'était rien du tout parce que je
suis fidèle ou non votre zizi oui j'ai
dit je quitte mes jeunes seront pas bons
et que du coup je me fâche pas avec mes
ex est bien certaine que je revois
qu'ils sont devenus un peu d'aidé plan
d'accord en prévente autres diplômés
arrêtez s'il vous plaît oubliez-moi
oubliez moi oui qualité de védas oui bah
moi je mange chez ig index
et je m'entends très bien avec lui j'ai
fait qu'il ya des bébés ne les ramènent
il me les montre mais quand mais parce
qu'il a débuté très fort entre elles
ouais j'ai un petit marvin la semaine
mardi des cumuls non mais quand vous
avez qu'un examen de ces ouvrages en est
un autre mais j'en ai un
j'en ai jamais dit je m'entends très
bien s'accommoder d'une ère mais parce
que faut qu'enfin il vers toi tu as des
zeks pour les mariés tout je suis
laissez moi tranquille ma vie personne à
koné je suis comme lui j'ai plusieurs
appartements
je suis content avec toute musique jeux
tout s'entend bien c'est vrai que toi tu
payes on sait pas d accès
[Applaudissements]
deux crs vous étrangers d'accord très
bien mais vous avez eu une vie avant de
plus avoir de zizi on a des vues en mai
allemande par exemple ce qui s'est passé
avec son zizi avons en contact jodar
hétérogènes très bon contact avec mes ex
d'accord franchement je suis et où je
les ai pas au téléphone mais quand je
les revois quand je les croise dans la
rue eh ben il nous arrive comme ça pour
rigoler comme ça pour pour le kiff 2
galoche qua non maison mariés sont
quatre enfants mais non bien sûr que non
non je vous jure on voit aucune ex et
est-ce que vous avez des axes qui
veulent se remettre avec vous alors qui
peut s'opposer le montant de mon contrat
oui
[Rires]
on rigole bien sûr mais c'est vrai que
non j'ai aucune ex qui m'a rappelé ni
rien alors est un beau nom un prénom
quand chez moi quand c'est fini c'est
fini
quand c'est fini c'est fini avance et
finir par voir qu'on cite quand j'ai
tourné la page
oui mais marque quand je tourne la page
rappelle qu' une ex mais personne me
rappelle ma personne ma pelle s'appelle
essentielle à l'air embarrassé
non pas du tout avec aucune ex mais
bonjour ce cas de figure oui oui soyons
voilà un exemple
oui on imagine oui une voile à une jeune
femme qui a été à une histoire avec vous
oui qui tout d'un coup vous voyez ces 10
mai quand même franchement il est drôle
intelligent il est beau gosse comme ça
alors c'est toi qui as he came c'est pas
moi qui l'a vue là on vous rappelle oui
vous aviez ou vraiment vécu une histoire
très sympa et voilà trouvait encore à
votre goût extraits vous demande de
prendre juste un café vous y allez vous
devez boire un café un thé un truc alors
un orangina d'accord est-ce que vous en
avez bien sûr par amy ekwalla parce que
je peux reposer parce que je suis les
toits ouais mais non mais non mais non
il n'y a aucune expansion à moi où je me
dis oui j'ai eu un petit goût de tutti
bien pas du tout problème c'est quand je
vois mes actes j'ai l'impression que
c'est mais tente aussi bien évoluer
canard c'est ça non je rigole en mai
parce que voilà si c'est l'impression
que c'est quelqu'un de ma famille mon ex
m'a dit je suis plus dedans c'est juste
une image
merci j'aime bien alors qu'est ce qui
s'est passé au niveau de la tenue là là
là moi vous voulez séduire ni annexe ni
un futur papa mais qu'est ce qui se
passe on vous allez faire en terre
inconnue mais c'est bien un été écoutés
je suis arrivé un peu en retard je suis
arrivé comme j'étais comme si mal dans
les deux sens comme ça sur les épaules
on va donner on va papa je sais combien
vous avez eu d'excès à peu près mais ce
qu'est ce qu'on appelle des zeks désaxé
livre est l'histoire voilà non la part
belle pour toi mais un jour 2 de
beinheim et bin 3 votre ancien mari
voilà
et puis d'eau avant et 2 avant c'était
qui je connais je connais toute la vie
de pénaliser les scellés c'est manon
j'étais beaucoup plus jeune puisque me
le mois et donc pas mal aussi su rester
très longtemps vécu quatre amoureux dont
l'allemand amoureux genre vous et à oui
vous avez dit je t'aime à quatre
personnes différentes et ça iloveyou
ouais tu écris c'est vrai ouais c'est
fou ça et lui une vingtaine j'ai
commencé très tôt par une vingtaine des
comores mais des vraies attentes autant
jeter sur ma liste c'est pas parce que
tu as une tête de comptable que t'es pas
mytho qui t'a dit je t'aime et où elle
pas forcément à tout mais en tous les
cas j'ai dit à chaque fois me suis je
suis un coeur d'artichaut j'ai cru non
non vous livre avec avoir une histoire
la première c'était c'était des amours
lycéenne
ouais c'était probablement la première
fois qu'on le faisait
non juste un attentat temps quand tu
nous dis 20 ex senna ex avec qui tu as
couché
oui des frères ça devient trop sexuel et
je les revues et je les revues après
après mon dimanche et 10 me et vous
trouver les racines ont massivement pas
non et re fois comprendre c'est pas ma
faute et amoureux de lui oui oui parce
que moi je ne considère pas l'amour
comme voilà à le faire à mon sens avoir
des sentiments
je suis allé sans je suis comme toi on a
déjà trop chine et de soi-même quoi on
est les mêmes les mêmes sait mais ne
serait pas aussi kelly toi d'où tu nous
as dit deux ou trois bandes ou trois
c'est à dire vrai sur le toit mais en
fait il s'est rien passé mais elle croit
que non louis ii on peut dire tout et on
va revenir
qu'est ce qui s'est passé qu'est-ce
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
glaciers deux vrais amoureux
ouais le premier le deuxième bah oui bon
ça vient ensuite j'ai eu je peux être
que si j'étais la seule à l'est mais
c'est pas fini alors là les mecs moi là
je suis comme vous oui c'est vrai tu
vois parfois moitié-moitié ça donne
beaucoup d'amour et ouais ils sont votre
retour vous savez quand vous donnez
beaucoup et que vous n'avez rien en
retour
je peux vous dire quand vous rentrez
chez vous n'avez qu'une seule envie
coeur lourd
c'est de regarder un inspecteur derrick
moi ça marié plus d'une fois moi j'étais
comme ça chorier j'avais la gueule à
zéro donc lui moi si je compte macau
aline ça fait enfin celle avec qui je
suis en ce moment et que je ne suis plus
posé mais après là il faut croquer mais
moi peur parce que je suis beau vase une
scène actuellement quoi rire et on s'en
fout
la 4g kkr et des quatre fois je t'aime
vous alors moi je suis un côté
vercingétorix
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le sort de l'histoire dans le sens de
l'histoire
alors moi je me suis marié je me suis
marié mineurs mais la bonne nouvelle
c'est que malgré ce que je suis devenu
les mecs qui voulait coucher avec moi se
manifeste encore très souvent je suis la
numéro vert d'ailleurs avec anton numéro
azur
voilà comment j'ai une vraie j parce que
on dit toujours que le premier amour
c'est ce qui marque le plus ouais et
quand j'étais petit y avait un mec est
amoureux de moi et alors nous a marqué à
deux à quatre marqueurs amnésie csc
celui mentionné baiser avec la langue et
tout est donc c'était admic ans finirait
par se marier tout patrick et puis je
considère qu'ils sont en effet séparés
par mes excuses comme j'en rêve mais un
jour il m'appelle et me dit faut
absolument que j'y suis je me suis
demandée en mariage c'est chiant je vais
lui dire et enfin il m'a dit je me marie
avec alors juste deux minutes à quel
moment de décrocher des sourires
merde là tu vois là ça y est cherry
saint gillois régaler puisque tout de
suite si vous le chiffre le chiffre
combien 6,1 à voir alain un arbre en
râlant mais couché ses dires à
l'horizontale trois touchés par ces mots
que tu vas tu en vises et là tu vas t'on
l'isi mais qu'est ce que nous et qui
n'ont je rejoignais mamie nous dans ce
qu'elle disait parce que lorsqu'on se
met en couple avec son premier amour
on souhaite toujours rester à vie avec
ceux d'hier c'est vrai c'est même
tellement qu'on aurait dû se rencontrer
plus tard
en fait au final quand il est plus tard
on se dit mais jamais la vie j'aurais
voulu être avec mes chiens ou vous
prenez pas la tête avec vos premiers
amours ça ne durera pas je dois croyez
pas du tout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
fin de match nul alors déjà combien vous
en avez vraiment vu toutes à peu près
tout ce qui vous avait dit je t'aime pas
ce que lui dit je t'aime comme il me dit
moi de l'oseille 1,8
non 8 - huit fois je t'aime l'a89
différents ouais ouais
en 2019
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
holy see études cada et groland dirait
une durée minimale pour estimer que
c'est une ex parce que ça me paraît
énorme 20 et 8 noeuds et 18ème à tout le
monde
non messieurs à la boulangerie de gounod
moins de protocole ajoute m on aurait
même est ce que c'est un rêve un minimum
un nom je sais pas mais je compte
vraiment est-ce que ça compte
quoi est-ce que quoi quand un silencieux
quand ça se chevauchent acompte
l'aïe a qu'une chose qui chevauchent et
vos paupières oui
alors oui oui mais tout compte
non à tout combat your way up 15 alors
qu'un non jeu aura pas besoin question
là tout compte
ouais tout compte fait au bout de quinze
15 x 2 voulez mais ne sais pas qui c'est
la femme qui vous êtes actuellement vous
avez le plus aimé à oui oui oui
[Rires]
j
[Musique]
la fin vous fait d'autres réponses 1
allée des gens vont venir vous chercher
gens qui vont vous allez refaire le
point que j'allais revenir dans dix
minutes accord géraldine maillet alors
moi mon premier amour
ensuite le père de ma fille et ensuite
l'homme de ma vie aujourd'hui
non ils ont 3 c3 la pléthore d'histoire
mais bhl et aurait tort mais ça c'est
clair
les ex et les histoires voilà donc 3 3
avait un deux trois rencontres
aquafresh3 quoi voilà j'aime bien ces
boues et géraldine maillet elle d'autres
belle quand elle dit je t'aime elle est
belle de born this way quelle moto se
pose jamais remonté sur deux étages et
très belle tapisserie vraiment bouder
revanche quand c'est fini à temps quand
c'est fini
j'ai prévenu ma gueule quand c'est fini
c'est fini si end à je peux vous dire
game over comme on lit un bouder non
mais c'est la vie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]